-Nate, welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much
for being here, buddy.
You got a lot going on.
You're in the middle
of The Raincheck Tour.
-Yes.
-And your Netflix special,
which I texted you, I loved,
"The Greatest Average American,"
was nominated
for a Grammy for
Best Comedy Album.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well...
Look, I want to say to for that,
I owe a lot to this show.
You have been
unbelievable to me.
I don't know if anybody --
But it's been a long time since
"Late Night with Fallon."
The Roots
have been unreal to me.
Everybody that works here
is unreal to me.
"Tonight Show's" been a huge
part of my career,
so I do want
to thank y'all for that.
I never forget it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I appreciate that, buddy.
But you're the best.
You put that work in.
I don't know how
you do all this stuff.
But, dude, Best Comedy Album.
Congrats.
That's giant.
That's massive.
-Oh, it's enor--
Dude, it's crazy.
I mean, it was like --
Yeah, I don't even know.
-That's so exciting.
-Yeah.
Well, I'm just from Old Hickory.
You know, we're not supposed
to get that stuff.
Are you getting recognized more
now that you're Grammy...?
-It happens -- yeah.
It happens more --
It's all, like, gradual.
Like, it's -- it's not crazy.
I can still go everywhere.
It's not a problem.
But, like, when I get --
Like I always take pictures.
Like, I --
None of this is lost on me.
I truly appreciate it.
But I always want to say --
Sometimes when it happens,
I want people to know, like,
when you leave
after we take this picture,
I then have to explain who I am
to like 30 people.
[ Laughter ]
So you put me in, like,
a whole thing --
Like, and I'll still do it,
but then you leave,
and they're like,
"Why did you --
Why did they do that?"
They just come up and ask.
Like, "Who are you?
Why did they do that?"
And they're mad about it.
And I'm like --
I go, "I'm a comedian."
They're like,
"I've never heard of you."
I was like, "I wasn't announc--
I wasn't walking around saying,
'I'm a comedian.'"
I was at the airport one time,
and this guy overheard that,
and he asks me, he goes,
"Is there any money in that?"
Like he might do it.
[ Laughter ]
Like, he -- just was like,
"If he could do it,
I mean, obviously I'll do it
if there's money in it."
-Oh, my God.
[ Both laugh ]
-I was just talking
to Cate Blanchett
about New Year's resolutions.
Are you that type of person?
Is 2022 new Nate?
-It's --
I mean, I hope so.
So, I have whole thing.
Do you another place
I got recognized recently?
McDonald's,
and that's always a tough one.
[ Laughter ]
If you're in McDonald's alone,
and then someone's like,
"Hey, are you Nate?"
You're like,
"Ah, yeah, I'm sorry."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause you're, like,
feeling kind of bad, being at --
-Why?
-I was 10 minutes from my house.
That guy was on a road trip.
Like, where it's like
that's all he has to do.
And he's like,
"Where do you live?"
I go,
"I live 10 minutes from here.
I'm here just regular day.
Like, this is just
my lunch today."
It wasn't a special thing.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I was sitting there,
I was holding a popcorn bucket
of soda just like --
It's so much --
Like, I drink --
I love it so much.
And you fill it up,
and it just keeps going.
It's so --
Like, when it keeps going --
It's long enough that you go,
"I've got to fix my life, dude."
And then --
-It just keeps coming.
-And it just keeps coming.
Like, you have a long time
to think about it.
And then, I'll take a little sip
to make sure everything's cool.
And then I'm like, "Well,
I'm gonna fill it back up."
You know,
I don't want to get stuck out --
What if I get lost
in the road somewhere?
And then, we took a picture,
and I had -- I love McDonald's.
We should show McDonald's
more respect, to be honest.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-People go in there
with sweatpants --
you should have a tuxedo.
It's the most successful
restaurant on Earth.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, it's an honor
you even open the door for me.
I come from nothing, so...
-Yeah.
You feel like people should give
them more respect, but that's --
-Yeah.
But he can't do that much of it.
I think, too --
You know what's hilarious, too?
So I have a podcast,
"The Nateland Podcast."
Hello, folks,
to the people listening.
But they -- it's --
I told that --
My mouth has been dry lately,
and I said it on the podcast,
and they were like, you probably
have type 2 diabetes.
So I was in that McDonald's.
When that guy came up to me,
I was googling how to check
for diabetes at home.
In a McDonald's,
just googling that.
Just at a low point, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- But that was like --
But I had to check it.
-You're googling that while
you're getting a 98-ounce soda.
-Yeah, and type 2
is the earned kind.
That's not --
You know, type 1 --
[ Laughter ]
You got to, you know...
You got to clock in
and clock out, every day.
-Gotta put the work in.
-You show up, dude.
They don't just give it to you.
You know?
You got to get after it.
I found out --
But I did an at-home test
before I came here,
'cause I wanted --
You have to, like,
stab your finger, you know?
-Yeah, sure.
-And my wife did it,
and she did it pretty hard.
Like, it's --
'Cause I couldn't do it.
So I had her do it
with the little thing.
And I mean,
it was just the most blood.
I was like,
"How deep do you want to go?"
You know?
And I am --
But I was on -- I'm, like,
the beginning of pre-diabetic.
Like, I'm right on the --
I'm a little normal.
It's like -- it'd be like
if there was, like,
a "No trespassing" sign,
and you walked in,
and you heard a gunshot,
and you're like,
you can either just go be normal
or you can be like,
"Well, I'm gonna go see
where that gunshot came from."
You know, like --
[ Laughter ]
I'm right there
on the edge of -- yeah.
-Yeah, with your diabetes.
-That's how I look at diabetes.
-Are you cutting back on sugar?
-I don't know, man.
I had gummy --
[ Laughter ]
I do need to.
I'm reading a book about it,
'cause I do think
I'm addicted to sugar.
So I eat ice cream every night.
And it's so much ice cream.
I like ketchup.
I like to use enough ketchup
that the person next to me
has to go,
"Man, that's a lot of ketchup."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like that's --
[ Applause ]
They have to feel like
they have to get involved.
They're like,
"That's a lot, isn't it?"
And I'm like, "Is it?
I don't know."
-Wow.
-I'm not -- yeah.
I don't --
I eat --
I ate gummy bears last night
in the hotel.
And I didn't want to,
but I love them so much.
[ Laughter ]
-Nate, this is terrible.
-I love french toast
and pancakes,
and I eat it every day,
and it makes me so tired.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know,
and I never blamed the pancakes.
I'm like,
"What is up today, man?
Like I -- I guess
I didn't get sleep last night."
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to bed,
and immediately I have to go --
'Cause I went to the doctor,
like, to get a physical,
So they go through it,
they're like,
"What's your family history?"
Like, I don't --
I've never asked, like --
How do I know
what my family history is?
Just on the holidays, be like,
"All right, raise your hand
if you got diabetes
in the room. Let's go.
Let's just go through everybody.
How many heart attacks
we got in the room?
I got a physical coming up."
-That's a bummer, yeah.
But how is mom and dad?
How are your parents doing?
-The parents are great,
and everybody's doing great.
My parents are downsizing
to a --
they got a home with zero steps.
That's what
they've been looking for.
-Yeah.
-They were -- They wanted --
They said, "Zero steps,
or if we can find a place
where we could always walk down
would be great."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-We found them one
with zero steps,
and so my mom --
she's at the age
she wants a koi pond.
There's an age
you never want one,
then you hit an age,
and you're like,
"That's all I've ever wanted."
[ Laughter ]
So we were gonna go get her
a koi pond for --
We did one for this past
Mother's Day.
And so we were gonna go dig
the hole and do it ourself,
and, dude, I don't know --
Have you ever dug a hole before?
Because it's maybe the hardest
thing you ever do in your life.
[ Laughter ]
You see it on TV and movies,
and you're like,
"I'll just dig this hole real
fast," and you start doing it,
you're like, "I guess it's all
CGI," because it's impossible.
[ Laughter ]
You can't --
It takes forever.
And you know it did?
It made me realize, I was like,
"This is why so many people
get caught,
when they kill someone,
with a shallow grave."
That's how hard
digging a hole is.
Even when you're digging
the most important hole
of your life...
[ Laughter ]
...it's so hard that
you're like, "All right.
I think that's good enough
right there."
You know...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"No one will ever find him."
-Someone's like, "Oh."
-Cover it up.
-"Could be..."
They're like,
"Well, his hand's sticking out,"
and you're like,
"Put a leaf over it, dude!
No one's gonna come up here."
-Cover the -- yeah.
It's so hard that,
I swear to you,
my mom's koi pond
is aboveground.
[ Laughter ]
-An aboveground koi pond.
-Aboveground koi pond.
-You're welcome, Mom.
Nate Bargatze, thank you so much
for coming on our show
every time.
"The Greatest Average American"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Check out natebargatze.com
for tickets.
See him live
on The Raincheck Tour!